[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltweit habe ich ganz besondere gäste
sind jahreszeugnis bei mir
peter und militär und wir werden jetzt
gemeinsam mit samira und ella unseren
zwei weihnachts elfen weihnachtskekse
packen
ich glaube dieses video wird alles
andere als normal aussieht gut aber die
hat schon angefangen als die zutaten
zeigen wir haben hier nämlich bisschen
mehl damals im dinkelmehl etwas butter
zucker salz eigelbe unternehmen tonga
war okay wir machen einfach einen ganz
normalen butter tykwer tragen sich
überlastet euch kurz die küche trifft
nämlich mit ella zusammen schon mal die
butter mit dem zucker und in eiern
alabama hier bisschen butter wright
genau ein bisschen mehr ja dann ist gut
da kannst du dich hier noch einmal die
geschwindigkeit
wir müssen festhalten die schüssel
eigentlich irgendwie worden weil die
anderen kinder punsch trinken beim
kinderwunsch gemacht was ist da drin
alles sind wir selber zum kinderspiel
ich auch irgendwie so ein traktor
absoluten und was kommt das jetzt rein
was ist das weißt du wieviel stopp stopp
stopp
das ist zu viel vielleicht ist mein
leben
das ist tom carbon ja schon mal nicht
ja wo nachricht ist für dich dann jeder
definiert ist ein bisschen anders und
nicht mal ein bisschen für mich riecht
sehr wie waldmeister sagt ja jetzt
machen wir hier noch mehrheit
naja wer will schöne kinder backen
das heißt mit der muss haben sieben sagt
ja ja ja mehr salz und zucker schmal als
- und machte den komoren ist ein tanker
bohnen
das sind die tonkabohne diesen schwarzen
na ja die sind giftig wenn man zu viel
davon ist also dann machen wir dieses
wohnzimmer sicht und muskat genau machen
wieder hier rein
[Musik]
lubitz gebeten da kommt macht es dann
langsam tut mir ja den eisigen griff
jetzt mal wie katzen aus anderer bürger
doch die sammlung von der arbeit spaß
ich glaube seine mutter gucke nicht hier
brauchen wir dann jemand die ermittler
wo genau und gleich haben wir genug zeit
das mal gleich nochmal in choco schoko
variante ist macht spaß
dazu sagen wir mit drei generationen was
wirst du später mal werden
ich habe mir gepflanzt und garten war
beim garten und landschaft gestalten
ja und dann weißt du denn habe ich ganz
zu geheiratet
und dann habe ich eine ganz große
familie sehr groß was heißt sehr groß
sieben eigene kinder
wow 13 enkel das türkische verhältnisse
sind es bei euch da kann ich für uns
immer gesagt naja der murat götter papa
hat nämlich auch die sind zu sechst wir
sind zu fünft fünf geschwister und mein
papa der herbst sage und schreibe neun
geschwister aber doch so ein riesen
um es aber auch noch ein paar den termin
oder anderthalb ja ach wie schön also
normalerweise muss der teig jetzt für
eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank ja
er muss erstmal der muss jetzt erst mal
ruhen
ich habe aber weil ich wusste die mädels
sind so eifrig habe ich schon mal ein
vorbereitet das heißt wir können gleich
weitermachen
ja denn auch kühl stellen noch mal
später noch mehr cache mal den kann es
jetzt flach hier drauf drücken dann
denken wir den abend voll da kannst du
die kekse ganz viele vor allem wollen
militär peter ja auch kekse mitnehmen
ganzen koffer folgen ja denkt sonntag
los ist wer wir noch machen nehmen das
mal ein bisschen ein bisschen so wie
nett ist so lecker ja ich habe ja schon
nicht so viel nicht so sehr dass er mir
jetzt nämlich mehr drin und die ersten
machen wolltest du ich habe schon ganz
was tolles mit ich mitgebracht ehrlich
ein kunstwerk von mir weil ich keine sie
durch du schreibst da an diesen stellen
also liebe führt dass ich im sommer kam
habe ich selbst gesagt dass das bunte
piccolo aber ist nicht zum benutzen
du solltest du eigentlich aufregen das
mag ich das land aber guck mal da peters
selber gemacht dass in der schule
gemacht
max man hole mir rat nämlich was für
euch ich glaube ich hier haben ihn
andere mal da drüben
ich habe zum studium auch stimmen
was hast du da auch das ist das gleich
mal hier nach hinten ist dass das ist
für mich jetzt wieder du willst alles
haben das video zeigt nun einmal so dem
small ihr sehen könnt ja mit uns gemacht
das habe ich nicht so schlimm
antimilitarist kamera erfahren das merkt
man richtig schön gemacht hat ja das
gemacht eine schwester groß und noch mal
vielen dank für die einladung sehr da
ich mir das wirklich mit kinderbüchern
ja schön dass ihr da seid
wir freuen uns sehr auch der geringe den
weiten weg aus berlin
pirelli ist beschäftigt ist sagte becker
dadurch dass mit dietrich ich habe mal
kurz den teig scheint also dass du
siehst ja aus wie poster war der held
meiner lieben laut einer weihnachtsmarkt
weil wieso willst du machen musst jetzt
wirklich kippen
celle wird es wieder ein doch doch
ganze bücher so durcheinander bringen
für seven i wieder angelangt wo gehobelt
werden dabei spielte bruder wieland die
kinder in sachen jetzt richtig zusammen
die kinder nur wir waren auf welchen wir
waren auch markennamen glauben braucht
mich jetzt schon entlassen hat jetzt
wird geräumt ja ja ja ja ich geb dir
sofort ich habe nur vor geknetet guck
mal hier könnt ihr jetzt den tag legen
lass mal die melitta die rolle drehen
jetzt dreht jetzt die rolle auch wo
sieben neuer sultaninen oder einstecken
können auch nicht draußen ja das kann
aber auch wo das später zuckerguss und
zuckerguss ich dass du profi bist du
kannst auch gerne ein bisschen mehr
ja es habe auch die rollen dran dann
wird er genau exakt 5 mm dick genau dann
backen alle gleichmäßig durch
doch nicht ausstellen noch nicht er habe
ich dort nicht so weit
wenn er unten klebt können wir noch so
ein bisschen
du darfst jetzt das erste ausstechen
guck mal was hätten sie gerne teure
sieht ihm vor augen
oh ja kommen wir später und das kommt
wahrscheinlich auf die schwarze genau an
der stelle nicht mitten rein
immer schön an ran wir stellen das jetzt
von rio die wahl noch nicht ausmachen
ich mache noch 1 hier machen
[Musik]
baghlan weihnachtsmann hält gemeinsame
singen da musste ich ja es stimmt wir
singen mit in der weihnachtsbäckerei
singen in rabat das passt stimmt man in
der weihnachtsbäckerei samira du kannst
kurz der cats doch dabei gibt es manche
leckerei und mit mancher nämlich eine
riesengroße gleich gern in der bäckerei
in der welt erreichen ist es fremd
geblieben von den plätzchen
[Musik]
liebenberg das rezept gemacht wer
steckte nicht weiter
den ländern normal ich weiß nur noch
sind dem ersten jahr ein
die finden da rein aber jetzt haben wir
jetzt nicht mein gott kundig das gewöhnt
sagt stylish
ich finde dann werfen braucht man auch
gar nicht so viele verschiedene
plätzchen rezepte die ausstecher
practice und schön marmelade retusche
machen sie den mandeln schokolade
traumhaft schönen zuckerguss und dann
hab ich gesehen hast du ein super gutes
sortiment ja ich kann man richtig zu
gast
naja kriegt man das ganze tal verstreut
na da können wir ja heute straße machen
ja genau und alle farben
das ist stets seine farben
in deutschland gab es nie so buntes
zurück ja es ist total toll dass du die
anti packen war und dann rettete schmidt
willst jetzt jetzt hat der stern einen
braunen fleck das ist ein schnellboot
der hat jetzt weber fricke ich friere
jetzt noch kurz ein dann behalten sie
beim backen in chili vor so tolle sachen
hat er nicht ausmachen
die muss auch platz macht
[Musik]
jetzt wird noch genau immer wenig mehr
sonst wieder zu trocknen
wie sehr genau und am besten immer ein
bisschen mit drehen jetzt in die
richtung
immer schön ohne genau ohne viel kraft
langsam rollen
das ist toll dieses diese studios und
vor allem hat man oft das problem dass
die tics sei ungleichmäßiger passieren
und dann verbrennen sehe oder haben
möchte druck das ist wenn du da leicht
drückst gleichmäßig stern von rio
da muss der lehrer siehst du selige
flexibilität kann ist auch richtig gut
das sieht man ja hat schon erfahrung mit
den kindern und enkelkindern original in
der großen familie und gemacht bis
weihnachten will haben wir gewachsen
ich glaube wir können gleich werbung der
backzeit noch bis in den tannenbaum
dekorieren und am besten immer gleich
große kekse auf einem blech statt
verbrennen das die backzeit nämlich
gleich da so die großen
und hier soll ist ein bisschen kleineren
wenn ihr beim backen drauf achtet das
gleichgroße ticks auf einem blech sind
haben sie auch die gleiche backzeit und
dann verbrennt auch nichts und alles ist
gleichmäßig durch
[Musik]
oh ja
ich habe unser sechstes flächen ja ja
dann sind wir hier fleißig
[Musik]
kubik gemeint im ganz besonderen
das ist ja das was wir jetzt überhaupt
noch was geht
aber ich bin aber sie ist wird der stein
war süß ja solch ein paar machen kannst
du mir ja gerne natürlich total witzig
mein partner nachts nicht zu drücken und
das witzige ist bei uns hier im süden
sagt man ja nicht hast du kekse sondern
husky xxl hat das spiel ja bei uns
gibt's nur kurz ihr die einen hut
bekommen ja danach sehen wir nicht
bekommen ja die familie in berlin auch
butterbrezel ja nicht bei uns hier die
schmecken ja ja bei uns in die immer
schon so ausgelaugt zu alt so alt die
frauen jetzt auch kurz ein dass die beim
backen die form behalten
dann kann man
[Musik]
die mutter war lehrerin gewesen
grundschullehrer bist du welche klasse
bis zu viel also nicht hatte eigentlich
auch die hauptschule hatte ich auch
größere kinder in hauswirtschaft die
neuen ttc elz sagt heutzutage kündbar
ja also bei uns hier auf dem land
wirtschaftlich doch nun haben sie es ja
da haben die auch in der grundschule
noch keine handys größe und das sind die
kinder echt lieb dystopische auch hier
bei uns sind viele mir ganz schwer der
abschied bei uns in die lehrer meistens
krank weil die kinder krank machen aber
eigentlich nicht mal die kinder sondern
die eltern die kinder können ja nichts
dafür sind nicht an die erziehung ja
weil sie bei uns waren noch schränkt
strenge sitten her in die lehrerin kam
stand wieder 1 1 beim begrüßungslied
gesunken und dann setzen heute haben uns
gesetzt und dann hofft er vor um so es
hat niemand etwas gemacht ohne dem
befehl der lehrerin
aber heutzutage ist das so dass die
lehrer die eltern nicht mal mehr respekt
vor den griff
[Musik]
richtiger weihnachtsduft ja bei 60 ganz
heißes nehmen sie mal heraus und man
sind die freundlichen lachen ja die sind
echt
das ist ein pflege
[Musik]
wie grün sind deine blätter
du kannst nicht nur schon seinerzeit
nein auch im winter wenn es schneit und
angel rothenbaum du kannst mir sehr
gefallen
[Musik]
ich glaube dass jetzt wo ich mich raus
nehmen kann ich trinke jetzt meinen
kinderpunsch und essen keks und ihr
dekoriert einfach oder wir sollen ja ihr
macht es so wunderbar mit den kindern ja
guck mal hier
[Gelächter]
es war richtig spaß bei dir haben mit
euch macht auch spaß und ich habe mir
auch noch richtig spaß beim zocken
er zeigt mir wie man das machen ja aber
ich bin nicht so der große zocker und
jetzt verraten
kinder sind so ehrlich der kindermund so
einen hund und jetzt waren in der
betrunkene und leggings sagt die
wahrheit kaviar die schwarzen tag
darf ich doch mal das zeug haben
mal sehen was wir haben und wünschte du
bist dabei macht den mal irgendwie weiß
aber nicht geklärte weise büro sachen
ein rosa schnee mit rosa gehört
[Musik]
dass drei generationen ins plätzchen
backen macht ziemlich spaß oder
ja ja ja ich fand es auch richtig schön
dass ihr zu gast bei mir in der küche
wartet also ihr könnt wirklich jederzeit
kommen können zu jeder jahreszeit
zusammenpacken angelegt anrufen genötigt
und wenn ihr dieses leckere plätzchen
rezept haben wollt dann schaut einfach
auf meinem blog vorbei aufs ellis - blog
de oder in der kostenlosen app da findet
ihr das rezept ganz genau kann es euch
als favorit speichern und immer mit
plätzchen backen und ich glaube wir
schnappen uns gleich noch so ein
kinderpunsch genau setzen und erst ein
break so richtig toll dass ihr den
weiten weg aus berlin hergekommen seid
schön dass du uns ein müller und wollte
noch zum abschluss ein lied singen
okay was singe mir in tomball
schneeflöckchen weißröckchen wann kommst
du geschneit du nun dein weg ist so weit
kommt setzt dich anfängt zu lieblich
stirn malt blumen und wir haben dicht
und wir haben uns gern genau und wie man
die partie
vielen dank für die 1 seither wird haben
noch neid wir können einfach noch
zuschauen
[Musik]